[Aplausos]
decenas de miles de opositores vio los
rusos marcharon contra alexander
lukashenko belarús registró otra jornada
histórica en la que se exigió libertad
en el país y la dimisión del presidente
al que acusan de fraude en las
elecciones del 9 de agosto las marchas
en minsk llenaron las principales calles
de la capital aunque la policía trató de
impedir el avance de la manifestación en
algunos puntos vine aquí para expresar
mi desacuerdo con los resultados de las
elecciones por supuesto expresar mi
solidaridad con las personas detenidas y
los presos políticos estoy a favor de la
paz de belarús pero no de lukashenko
durante la jornada la policía registró
decenas de detenciones algo que la
oposición denuncia y asegura que en el
país hay cientos de presos políticos a
pesar de las tres semanas de protestas y
huelgas en muchos sectores
lukashenko mantiene el poder y amenaza
con tener el apoyo de rusia en caso de
emergencia de hecho la dini putin llamó
a su homólogo bielorruso por su
cumpleaños y le invitó a moscú para
dialogar algo que no parecen temer desde
la oposición este ya no pues venimos
siempre ya no tenemos miedo el miedo se
ha ido hace
venimos a apoyar a nuestra gente si
nuestros hombres son detenidos entonces
las mujeres protestarán si comienzan a
detener a las mujeres más hombres
protestarán ahora protestaremos siempre
es inevitable luego de 26 años de poder
indiscutible de alexander lukashenko
belarús encara su crisis política más
fuerte con una oposición unida frente al
oficialismo que tiene la idea de
restaurar las elecciones libres en este
país
[Aplausos]